In summary, UML provides a rich vocabulary for modeling system structure.
And the UML class model diagram exhibits many, many different features.
However, there's no need for you to use all of its affordances. Particularly at
the start of the modeling process. Never the less, each affordance implies
a question to be answered. What is the multiplicity? Are these values ordered?
What's the qualifier? Does the system that you are modeling,
exhibit the property expressed by that affordance? One of the important
benefits of modeling, is that it encourages you to face these questions early,
in the development process. Because if you forget and they,
they may later come back to haunt you.